me we have an admission from Alistair
Carmichael the former Secretary of State
for Scotland that he was responsible the
Alister mark-up Carmichael has published
this statement he says the Cabinet
Office has today published the
conclusions of its inquiry after an
internal account of the First Minister's
discussions that's Nicola Sturgeon with
the French ambassador was published in
The Daily Telegraph on the third of
April he says I had not seen the
document before it was published in The
Daily Telegraph however I was aware of
its content and agreed that my special
adviser should make it public I should
not have agreed this it was an error of
judgement which I regret I accept full
responsibility for the publication of
the document i have written today to the
First Minister and to the French
ambassador to apologize to them both had
I still been a government minister I
would have considered this to be a
matter that required my resignation I
have therefore informed the cabinet
secretary that I will decline my
ministerial severance payment well
that's likely to be several thousand
pounds in actual fact he was still a
minister right up until the general
election this if you remember course the
huge route at the time Nicola Sturgeon
denied it at the time mr. Carmichael
made a very sort of flippant remark
these things happen he said well it did
happen and now he's cuffed of being
responsible Nicola Sturgeon will be
furious this is not over yet there will
be a furious rally I'll have to make a
policy to the House of Commons I imagine
Alistair Carmichael is in deep trouble
now he's been forced to own up that
he'll eat this very damaging memo